معنا من بيروت العميد الياس حناء الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي حضره العبيد اذا
سناء جديده
وحساباتها برايك تختلف عن مكانه في الايام
الماضيه ام اييي ام هي امتداد النسق في
العمليات
عبد القادر هي امتداد هي عمليه تاقلم
تكتيكيه منذ المرحله الاولى ب 24 شباط
وحتى الان نحن في مرحله جديده والامور
تتعلق بالتقص بحاله الارض والقتال
بالتمويل الغربي لاوكرانيا خاصه الدفاعات
الجويه
بقدره تونسيه على الاستمرار في هذا القصب
والتحذير لمرحله ما بعد الشتاء
لحرب جديد اعلن الرئيس بوتين في خطاب راس
السنه الجديده عن اهدافه يعني اليوم يتحدث
عن سياده روسيه همم استقلال روسيه وهذا
ياخذنا الى اربعه اقاليم التي ضمها يعني
بالنسبه له تحرير ما تبقى من ذكر وخرصان
هل هذه الاهداف وما اعلن عنه في خطابه في
راس السنه
واقعي بالنظر لما يجري الان على الارض
وهذا الدعم القوي من الغرب
ليلى الامر يتعلق باستمراريه الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا اليوم منذ العام منذ سبتمبر
2022 وحتى الان 600 مسيره باتجاه اوكرانيا
من شاهد وغيرها اسقط عدد كبير منها قذيفه
او مسيره شاهد عشرين الف دولار ولكن صاروخ
النسام 400 الف دولار هنا ياتي الكلفه من
وين استمرار عمليه القصف بالصور من كما
يقال بعمليه الاغاره فقط لاستنزاف مخزون
اوكرانيا
واختبار مدى قدره الغرب وعزمه على
استمراريه المساعده لاوكرانيا طيب عندما
نسمع الرئيس الاوكراني همم يطالب بالمزيد
من الاسلحه النوعيه ويقول ان النصر هذه
السنه باتا اقرب من اي وقت مضى نحن في
امام جزء من الدعايه طبعا متبادله من
الطرفين ام ايضا امام نسب يختلف يوم بعد
يوم في طبيعه المواجهه بين الطرفين
عبد القادر من الضروري ان يقول رئيس
الجمهوريه وهذا العامل السياسي الذي يتابع
العمليات العسكريه هو عندما ذهب الى
الكونجرس قال هذه ليست منا منكم هي واجب
عليكم لانه ما تقوم به اوكرانيا هي حمايه
الغرب حمايه اوروبا وحتى حمايه حلف الناتو
المرحله القادمه خطاب سياسي ولكن الامر
دائما يتعلق بالتنفيذ على الارض مع اعتقاد
الغرب بصوره قاطعه انه لا يمكن على سبيل
المثال العوده الى ما كان في 2014 او ما
قبلها خاصه في تحرير شبه جزيره القرم الى
اي درجه كانت موسكو تحسب حساب التكنولوجيا
الحديثه يعني في السابق كنا نتحدث عن
احداثيات يجب ان توفر من جانب جهات
استخباراتيه الان هاتف محمول بيد جندي
يمكن ان يدل على موقع وهدف جديد للاصابه
هذا العنصر همم هل يعد عنصر اساسي الان في
الحرب والى اي درجه يؤثر على مجرياتها على
الارض
الليله دائما هناك ما يسمى بالتكتيك الذي
يفاجئ العدو وقدره العدو على التاقلم لمنع
هذه المفاجاه ونحن في هذه المراحل المرحله
الحاليه يعني مسيره هناك مضاد للدروع مضاد
للمسيرات دائما هناك مفاجاه تكتيه اليوم
هذه نتحدث عن الهاتف الخلوي انه خلق
لقواعد الامن العاملان للقوى التي تقاتل
وهذا خطا لا يخطر 400 جندي في مكان معروف
13 كيلو متر عن همم الجبهه همم استعمال
خلوي وبالتالي كان هناك تجربه مع الهامس
انه قادر على القصف بدقه فاذا خلل عملان
كفيف جدا خطير جدا على مستوى الاداء
الروسي وسيؤثر على المعنويات على الاداء
في المراحل القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك العميد
الياس انا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من
بيروت شكرا